and you guys know my situation my life
is kind of like an open book to the
tabloids i'm not here to be a victim um
i live with victims my whole life i'm
just a normal girl brittany jean
it's me
britney spears has had quite the year
hosting duty has to do man
and some might even say 2021 was her
year it's just a groundbreaking day
thanks to this after 13 years on
november 12th britney spears officially
gained freedom
been in the conservatorship for 13 years
from speaking out in court about her
struggles publicly for the first time in
june to switching lawyers to finally
breaking free from her conservatorship
after a tough fight against her family
it's been a whirlwind journey for
brittany i've worked my whole life
i don't owe these people anything
hopefully my story will make an impact
and
make some changes
in the corrupt system and her fans have
been there every step of the way
and the free brittany movement you guys
rock because of you i honestly think you
guys saved my life the singer also
received an outpouring of love and
support from many friends and celebs
that makes me so happy and
i just wish her all the love and
happiness in the world because she
deserves it i'm here to support her if
there's anything she needs in private
it's good to see and it's good to hear i
care for her and i wish her all the best
and
i'm so happy that she gets to have the
future that she wants now
[Applause]
and the cherry on top to her new found
freedom well britt is getting hitched
look at that
you like it the pop sensation got
engaged to boyfriend samus gary back in
september after nearly five years of
dating and a change in her
conservatorship that previously didn't
allow her to wed i won the biggest
wedding in the world it's up to her
she's wearing the pants now
another big moment for spears in
september the songstress made the time
100 most influential people of 2021 list
cool very cool britney's pal and one of
her biggest advocates paris hilton
authored an essay for times list calling
spears iconic a legend a fighter and the
sweetest soul
what i feel like doing
[Music]
so let me go
and just listen 2021 also marked the
20th anniversary of brittany's
self-titled album you know the one that
featured hits like
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
the album became 2001's most successful
debut by a female topping the charts and
breaking records today it sold over 10
million copies worldwide
happy birthday to me happy birthday to
me another major milestone for the pop
star she turned the big 4-0
happy birthday to you
celebrated with fiance sam in style on a
private jet the celebration was complete
with balloons a beautiful floral cake a
mariachi band and the couple even caught
view of some stunning fireworks
at the time a source told et that
britney felt that this was the first
year in a very long time that she
actually had reason to celebrate her
birthday because she is finally living
and enjoying life quote brittany is
looking forward to this new chapter and
to what 40 will bring adding quote her
team is being very thoughtful about
britney's next steps and everyone wants
to make sure she feels supported and
taken care of so what's next for britt
well we'll wait and see
what am i going to do now take each day
at a time the main thing is to enjoy
life i just want to be a happy person
[Music]
you